Just printed off a little list
of things I thought we could talk about.
Today we're talking about the clickbait,
the collabs, what's happening on YouTube,
and the future of "The King of Random."
So hey guys.
First of all,
Happy Father's Day
to any fathers out there.
I know by the time you're watching this,
it's no longer Father's Day,
but today is Father's Day.
I wasn't really planning to film a video,
but after all the drama
that I've seen in the comments
in the last couple of days,
I thought it'd be good to just sit down
and have a heart-to-heart.
I'm here with my wife,
- one of our little babies here.
- Hi!
Say, hello world.
Eight weeks yesterday.
Uh, he's four of four.
We have four boys now,
and the other three are
at the grandparents.
So this is our chance to talk to you.
Now I don't have a lot of time
to edit this video.
So it's almost gonna be
like a live stream, very minimal editing.
There's not gonna be any frills, flares,
any fancy transitions
or anything like that.
It's just you and me, a heart-to-heart,
getting out everything on the table.
So remember guys,
everything is an experiment.
In this last week, you know,
I went down to L.A.,
I collaborated with a lot
of different YouTubers.
Um, some I knew really well,
some I didn't know very well at all.
And it all for fun, it was an experiment.
And I learned a lot
by watching your reactions.
I learned a lot about you
and hopefully you learned a lot
about you as well.
I hope the other thing that sticks out
is everything on my channel
is family-friendly content.
Uh, some of the people
that were on the channel
you may not like or resonate with.
Remember, they're on a journey
of their own as well.
You know, it's been eye opening for me
on where to take this channel
in the future,
what kind of standards
you guys respect and uphold,
and I've taken that to heart,
and I will make changes
and future decisions accordingly.
So let's talk about clickbaiting,
some of you had accused me
on becoming a clickbaiter.
Let's talk about what that means.
So... [chuckles]
To actually clickbait,
like real genuine clickbait,
is when you put up an advertisement
or a thumbnail or a description,
that has absolutely nothing to do
with the video, at all.
Just absolutely unrelated
whatsoever, you know.
That's clickbait.
Now if you take a thumbnail,
and you dress it up a little bit
and you make it look more attractive.
And if you change the title to be enticing,
and make you want to click,
that's called marketing!
That's called selling, guys.
- I mean--
- Which is what you want,
because you want to click on something
that you have a desire to click on.
I mean, if you're going to buy a house
and somebody painted the house
to make it look nicer,
would you accuse them of clickbaiting?
Because they're like, enticing you
to buy this house, making it better--
Making it seem better than it actually is?
Uh that's just-- that's good
old fashioned marketing guys,
and I've learned that
by watching other channels
I mean, doing the collaborations in L.A.,
there's a lot of creators
who put a lot of work
into their thumbnails...
that make them more clickable.
And that's what I'm going for.
I'm not going for clickbaiting,
I'm making my thumbnails more clickable.
So I hope you can appreciate that.
Because that's an added expense,
it's added time,
and it's something
I'm trying to do for you.
You always find good content in my videos
and you'll always find the thumbnails
and the titles related
to the content in the video.
Unless you're gonna sign up
for YouTube Red,
or you're going to, like, privately fund
The King of Random foundation
or something of that nature, um,
you're getting these videos for free.
And there's no such thing as free.
Somebody's paying for them
and that's the businesses
who are advertising with Google.
That's how you're paying so...
But ultimately, too, our service to you is
to create good quality content for free.
- That's our purpose.
- That's right.
So click-- click on those videos.
I guess that's all we have to say,
click on the videos, click on the videos!
I mean, your numbers,
your responses to the videos tell us
if we're doing better or worse.
If we put time and work
into our thumbnails
and you click more on them,
then obviously,
that's working,
we're gonna do more of it.
It's not clickbait, it's just marketing.
And the more you guys
actually click on these videos,
the more support it gives to us,
to have a team
- to bring more content to you.
- Exactly.
So it's really a win-win.
And that brings up another point here,
I want to talk about AdBlockers.
Some of you are very proud
about using AdBlockers.
But you know when you do that,
it cuts the revenue stream.
And if the money doesn't come in
to pay for all these systems
to create these videos,
the videos are going to stop.
And there's nothing really keeping us
from stopping,
except that we think
that you still want the content.
So if you want it, we keep making it.
If you don't want it, we stop making it.
So...
Where do we go from here?
What's the next step?
So yeah, let's jump into it.
Let's just get everything out
on the table.
Who's The King of Random?
Where did it come from? Where is it going?
So a little about myself,
I'm Grant Thompson.
I'm now known as The King of Random.
But way back in the day,
I was born in Calgary, Canada in Alberta.
I grew up there, uh,
lived a few years in Calgary
and then we moved south of the city
to a little small town
that didn't even have street lights
or even a McDonalds.
And in that small town environment,
I started going to school,
but I actually started having
a really hard time in school.
I felt like I got bullied,
I got called names.
And a lot of people--
Actually a couple people in particular,
went out of their way, every day,
to tell me what a loser,
and what a geek I was.
Um, the hard thing about that situation is
I didn't feel like I had any place
or group I belonged to.
I wasn't a jock, I wasn't a nerd,
I wasn't anything.
I was by just myself,
which was really frustrating.
Uh, I would--
I wouldn't get picked on teams.
I'd always be the last one
to be picked on teams
even though I thought
I had some kind of athletic ability.
There was just some stigma
of not wanting to be with me.
So, I think that kinda hurt my feelings.
Now during that time of confusion,
my dad did something for me
that probably changed my life at age 14.
He bought me a ticket
to go fly in an ultra light glider.
And that was my first experience getting
into an airplane, flying above the city.
What that did for me is
it changed my perspective,
because this huge city
that was intimidating to me
was now so small.
Uh you know,
the people and the cars look like ants.
And I could now really see in context
where that city fit in
to at least a bigger part of the world.
That's when I knew
that I could make decisions
that would change me life,
I wasn't stuck in one place.
So what I started doing was
I started going after everything
that made me feel better about myself.
Everything available.
I went and got my drivers license,
'cause that made me
feel better about myself.
And then I got--
What's the next license after that?
I started driving buses, school buses,
and started doing trips
and tours for school kids.
Then I got my license
to drive motorcoaches,
the big 55 passenger buses,
and I started driving rock bands
on tour around Canada,
which was very cool. [chuckles]
Then I took two years
of my life and I went
and served a mission in England,
where I supported myself
on money that I'd saved up
and I took two years
to go tell people about my beliefs.
And that was really strengthening,
because I was knocking on doors,
talking to people,
sharing, uh, very personal information.
And that taught me a lot of work ethic
and it got me into a lot of routines
that when I returned back,
I was ready to go.
Now I knew that whatever I was gonna do
was going to take a lot of money.
And rather than going
to college or university at the time,
I wanted to make sure...
I had a purpose for what
I was going to learn before I learned it.
Um, I took a lot of time
to contemplate what I was interested in,
but I wasn't finding any colleges
or universities that met those needs
and I didn't really have a purpose to find.
So while I was waiting
I got a job on the oil rigs
as a roughneck up in northern Canada,
where it was -60°C
and we worked outdoors 12 hours a day.
- If you could believe that. So--
- Wow. Sounds cold.
Pretty crazy and we would
literally work 14 days straight
and then I have a couple days off.
I actually lived in my car,
because I could save more money that way.
They'd give us money for hotel and foods
and I actually just slept in my car
so I could save money faster.
Long story short, I saved up enough money
to buy a small airplane.
And I felt, at the time,
inspired to become an airline pilot.
So I figured the best way to do that,
was talk to people who had become pilots.
And after listening
to a number of stories,
I decided to buy my own airplane,
build the flight time myself.
And that eventually carried me
over to Hawaii,
where I got a job as a cargo pilot
for about a year,
flying from Honolulu
to all the inter-islands around Hawaii.
And once I got enough flight time,
I got hired by a commercial airliner
back in the mainlands.
So I moved back to the mainland
and worked 11 years
as a commercial airline pilot.
I bought my first house.
That's where I met my wife.
- And, uh, we--
- Where I bought my first house.
She bought her house right beside me.
And we kept both of them,
and we fixed them up, we rented
them out and we kept buying houses,
fixing them up, renting them out,
until we had 11 houses,
fixed up and rented out.
So we got a business in real estate,
and the money that was coming in
was actually paying for our living expenses,
and so we started to have a little
bit more freedom with our time.
I was still working on the airlines,
but we built a business in real estate.
[Baby noise]
Now when the housing market
started to crash, we sold everything,
and we put that money into investments,
and started living off of the interest.
And the cool thing about that scenario,
is now we had that time freedom,
that everybody wants to have.
And it was a challenging time for me because...
now I had the opportunity to say, "What
have I always wanted to do with my life?"
And kind of live the dream of "if
money were not an object" or an issue,
what would you do with your time?
And I remember talking about this
with my wife, and what we ended up, uh,
what I ended up coming with- was
I would love to just do things that
I love and make videos about it.
[chuckles] So...funny enough,
you know that's kind of what
got us into what we're doing, so...
If you could do anything you wanted
and money weren't a factor, what would you do?
For me, at the time, it was making videos.
We've also had four kids and
we've now been married for 10 years,
but about 5 years ago,
we sold all of our houses we used
that money to invest in investments.
And for the first time in my life,
I had a little bit of free time,
where I could scale back my hours at
the airlines and I had sometime to work,
to tinker to figure out how things work.
Now, that was also around 2008-2009.
When everyone was talking about a Great Depression,
and falling back into the old ways where, you know,
maybe there's gonna be an
apocalypse, people falling off the grid,
you know banking systems crashing, who knows?
One thing I learned from reading books about history,
is that some of the wealthiest people got their wealth,
during the biggest crisises,
and it all has to do with
opportunity meaning preparedness.
So, although I had a great career as an airline pilot,
I felt really insecure about my knowledge,
because I live in this time where we
have lights, we have electricity, we have...
drinkable water,
we have toilets that we can just flush,
and I didn't know about how
any of those things worked.
Where does it all come from?
And if you were to go back 200 years in history,
when there were no electric light bulbs
and you could be the person to...
to revolutionize the economy to
bring light to people's homes,
would you be able to sufficiently
explain how that work,
do you know how it works enough,
to where you could be that person
who invents that industry,
can you generate electricity?
And for me, I thought, I... I...
can't explain how that works,
and yet we live in this...
this great time of technological
advantages where everything's available,
and i'ts on then internet, it's on
the Wikipedia, it's on YouTube.
So...
so what I decided to do was
devote my life to learning,
I wanted to learn how to weld,
I wanted to learn how to make circuit boards,
I wanted to learn how to be
Tony Stark, I wanted to learn...
how light bulbs work and be able to
explain how everything works around me.
The problem, I was finding is that as I was
going around to universities and colleges
looking for programs that taught this,
I couldn't find anything that would meet those needs.
So what I decided to do instead,
was try to a course of online study,
the school of Grant Thompson,
pick something that I'm interested
and learned as much as I can about it,
until I can recreate it at
home using household materials.
And in all my years in college,
I'd never seen anybody work as hard at
studying as Grant did during that time.
It's very... very focused study and it was very exciting.
Because every morning I would jump
outta bed to go learn something new.
I was getting old televisions and hacking
them apart, I was ripping apart circuit boards,
do you remember when I was down there
de-sauteing all the components from...
circuit boards and then getting on Wikipedia
to find out what these things were,
you know, capacitors and triodes and
diodes...
- M-hmm.
- and transistor and resisters.
Yeah, our house became a factory
of all these gadgets taken apart.
- [chuckles]
- Microwave-ovens and homemade rocket fuel...
that time we almost burned down the basement?
Yeah, of the house we were renting.
Yeah! [both laughs]
We actually used one of those
chemical fire extinguishers
and it took 2 days to clean up the mess.
- Yeah!
- So...
those things happened.
I saw, if there's going to be another Great Depression,
the best thing that we could do, is get prepared
with knowledge.
So I wanted to start studying how
things worked, I want to learn...
how did our economy get to where it's at
and we lost all that for some reason,
could we rebuild it using common
materials around the house,
basically. So thus was born
"The King of Random."
So to make a really long story short,
what ended up happening is, as I was
tinkering with things and making discoveries,
I was learning about things that...
- that aren't taught anywhere else.
- Mm-hmm.
Really, I was learning about how to
generate electricity, how to make motors,
how to play with high voltage
and, uh, how to make rocket fuel
and things of this nature.
And every time I go to somebody's house
and just talk about these things I was learning,
they would look at me like, "Who are you?
Where did you come from?"
Like, "Why do you know this stuff? That is so random!"
And one friend in particular, every time
I'd come over and he'd listen to this stuff,
he'd be like, "You know what?
You are like the king of random!"
Yeah, it seemed to be just a random different project
every time he would come visit us.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's periodic every few weeks
or whatever, but it was just always something different.
- I mean, really intense.
- I mean, we're like dripping water through...
pop cans to generate electricity,
we were making Tesla coils,
we were making salt water capacitors,
a lot of really crazy stuff.
Yeah, what was that one that was like
creating rain and ozone and the smell of rain.
Yeah, I had a spark gap that would
actually make our house smell like ozone.
- Which is the smell that comes after a thunderstorm.
- I love that smell. [laughs]
- Yeah.
- That name kind of stuck "The King of Random,"
the king of random projects,
the king of random experiments, so...
about this time I was thinking if so many
people are finding value out of this,
what if I started a
YouTube channel to kind of give back?
I was learning so much information from
the internet from Wikipedia and from YouTube.
The problem I was having, is that
the format's people would upload in,
we're so difficult to follow,
15-20 minutes of somebody with their handy-cam
very shaky footage,
very hard to distill the information,
[baby noise] and half the time information
was wrong... that was a good pooper.
- Yeah! [laughs]
- Nice job bud, get out there, get out there.
Our little man's doing a job right now.
[laughs] Brief intermission,
we got to do a diaper change.
[laughs]
So because I was coming into all this new
knowledge that wasn't really shared.
I decided what I was going to do,
is become the man I was going to step up
and bring content to YouTube in a
very condensed, concise formula,
of how to do things that aren't usually
done and make discoveries, inventions,
and bring them to the world
in a package, where I've done all the prototyping
and experimenting.
Also one of the gifts I've noticed,
as the wife of this incredible man,
is that he's got a gift
to be able to take a lot of information
and distill it, if you will or condense it
down into the most important things
they're really easy to
understand and very shareable.
And so that's kind of something
he's always been really good at...
- as well.
- Thank you.
- Mmm-hm.
And I had a lot of fun
with it, um, because...
it was really reverse engineering society
and my goal was to be able to
know how to do everything...
that happens in society to be
able to purify water to keep, uh,
a roof over my family's head to be able to start fires
without matches.
What? Because if those aren't available,
um, I mean heat is one of the most
essential things you need access to you,
so you find a lot of my experiments have
to do with starting fire without matches.
So this started my journey on YouTube
and you got to remember I'm working as
a full-time airline pilot and I have two kids...
at the same time. We're living a basement
apartment because we sold all of our properties
and we've got our money in investments
so that I can actually be taking the time...
to do this
tinkering at home.
You know the other thing I that I remember,
we would have late-night conversations
about where YouTube could go because
even before we posted our first video,
we'd have conversations like this could lead to...
you'd becoming known,
uh, you know it could lead to fame,
it could lead to going to television shows,
it could lead to you know a lot of big
opportunities, do we really want that?
Um, you know, because I'm kind of a private
person, I want to protect my family,
I want to give them a good life and so
coming out on the Internet [baby noise]
and sharing these things,
these things was very risky for me.
So when I started presenting my videos,
- you notice there are only my hands in the
videos you never saw my face.
- Mmm-hm.
It was very anonymous,
in some ways, and it came out of nowhere,
there's no history, there's no story,
you don't know anything about me
or why I started posting those videos,
until today.
In contrary to what you might
think Grant is a very private person,
hence the reason he just had his
hands in a lot of the videos,
because he didn't want to be seen
on camera and so as he's...
grown and worked through those things
- you guys have also kind of seen
that evolution on "The King of Random."
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah and YouTube itself has
been it's very own journey,
there's been a lot of things that happen
since we started posting on YouTube,
there's been a whole 'nother series of experiences.
The thing you got to realize, is when you
start posting videos on YouTube,
even if they're
excellent excellent videos...
nobody's going to watch them.
Because there's so much content on YouTube,
there needs to be some way to stand out so I was...
I was putting a lot of time into making videos
and getting 100, 200 views.
So I had to get creative and find
other ways to market myself,
I started writing articles for websites,
I started posting, uh, weekly...
how-to step by steps on different, uh, websites
that would eventually feature me on the front page
and that would
drive a little more traffic.
For the year-and-a-half of posting videos on YouTube,
they hardly got watched at all, I mean,
for the first almost a year-and-a-half,
we gained only 50,000 subscribers
by posting a high quality
video every single week.
And when we hit that 50,000 we were so excited,
I bought Grant a bouquet of lighters,
- because what else do you get "The King of Random?"
- A bouquet of barbecue lighters,
- [laughs]
which actually was like the perfect gift
for me, that was amazing.
Now, as an airline pilot, I could just pick up
extra shifts and make, you know,
a fair amount of money.
So to be taking time away from
that and making videos instead,
where I'd make like five dollars after
putting a hundred hours into a video,
didn't really make much sense at all.
And I can tell you, I was a really rough time posting
every week for a year and when I post every week?
you understand there's like 12 hours a day
going into these videos sometimes more.
- Yeah.
- I mean, to the point where
it is like affecting our family relationship.
Yeah, and at the time Grant was
flying nights, so he'd go out do a flight,
sleep 2 or 3 or 4 hours at a hotel,
fly back and then work all day...
at home.
And so I'd start getting bags under my eyes,
my eyes would turn purple, my eyes will be bloodshot.
And if I ever did have a video with my eyes in it,
a lot of people make, uh, jokes
about me being high or being stoned,
uh, really what it was a sleep deprivation,
because I was burning the candle at both ends.
And being a dad and a husband.
That's true, I mean we're bouncing a lot,
plus our real-estate business and everything else,
on top of that.
So that was pretty crazy...
but once the channel popped,
you know, we hit 100,000 subscribers
and then we put out some...
summer life hack videos and those
started trending and doing really well.
And our channel started
getting recognized and growing...
to the point where I could really cut back my hours
at the airline it's quite a bit.
Start taking days off and sleeping at home.
Yeah, and it's not necessarily that I was
taking days off, it just put more work
- into...
- Days off from the airlines.
Yeah, more work into creating the videos
and catching up a little bit on my sleep because...
I wasn't working the night shift as well.
The thing you gotta realize, every one of
those projects I was putting out,
were basically like inventions, I was taking
something, I was playing with it,
modifying it, doing a lot of back-end prototyping.
And I was filming all these videos myself
and I cannot tell you how much work...
went into making these videos.
Doing the scripts, doing the
filming, doing the editing doing the...
voiceovers, the musics, um,
and that's just getting the video done.
Then it's uploading and it's doing
the metadata and the SEO
and managing the comments and doing the annotations
and watching the views and trying
to understand the algorithm.
It's overwhelming, just listening to you and
I remember when you were doing all this...
and that
was overwhelming.
It's so much that goes into making these videos,
but I was very proud of the content it was
all very new interesting concepts.
- It was all passion projects too.
-Yeah.
But the thing was very validating, is...
this work got recognized,
it was getting appreciated it started
skyrocketing in numbers,
uh, the views would be popping some
videos that I was discouraged.
You know only had a couple hundred thousand views,
you know sometimes it would pop and in a month later,
it would have 10 million views.
So that was super validating to me,
when that started happening
and I'm very driven by success,
so when things start working out,
I'm very motivated to push even harder
to keep that up and to keep it going.
The problem was...
after about four years of
doing this and I was extremely tired,
you know burning the candle
and pushing hard, hard, hard.
Um, I was still putting out high quality content,
but the comments started to change.
I didn't feel like people were really
appreciating what I was doing anymore,
the expectation was...
you know,
"Your contents all great, why
don't you put out every day?"
"Why are you only putting out every week?" or "Every two weeks?"
"Why are you doing quick clips?"
"You know why don't you just give us the
whole video?"
Uh, you know wha--
"Where are all your awesome ideas?"
Um, you know, and this is funny
thing is even from day one,
people were like, "You used to be so awesome,
why aren't you doing awesome projects now?"
And then I put out a project that
was like more awesome
than anything that's ever been...
- And nobody would watch it, or
it would get lower views.
- Yeah.
Or, or the other thing would happen is like, you know,
a few months later, people would look back and say
"Well, why don't you do
projects like that anymore?" [scoffs]
You know, it's like...
whatever I make today, gets appreciated
like six months or a year from now,
it doesn't get appreciated in the moment.
So ever since day one, I've been told,
you know, "you're out of ideas, your channel is dying"...
[both laughing] You know,
"your content used to be so much better"...
Um, so I've been hearing this for like six years.
But, at about, I'd say, about the
four-and-a-half year point,
I'm starting to feel really low, I was burned out,
you know, I had a family, I'm getting kids,
they're getting old enough to do things with
and I'm on the computer every single day editing,
I'm prototyping, I'm tinkering, like there's...
every minute of every day goes
into making these videos.
And I'm starting to feel pulled
away from my family, because...
this is my priority, my family is my priority.
And I feel like making YouTube videos,
is a stark contrast between
spending time with my family
and it's really hard to find middle ground,
when you're working with the YouTube
algorithm and watch time
and people who are trying to keep up,
um, you know, with the channel and you know, keep things going.
Eventually hit a point, where the
comments were so bad,
you know telling me, that I wasn't doing enough
and I looked at the situation I said you know, "I
started making YouTube videos for you to
share the knowledge that I was gaining."
You know, I didn't need YouTube,
I didn't start making YouTube videos
because we needed the money,
in fact, YouTube was some of the worst
money we've ever made in our lives.
- Especially,
- Yep. True story.
working as an airline pilot and a real
estate business we made far...
greater amounts of money than
making YouTube videos.
I just... remember reading books about people like Tesla,
who did so many great things with their lives
and they were so wrapped up in their work,
but then they had so little to show for it?
Now I have a lot of respect for
those people but I didn't want to be
one of those people myself so...
everything that I learned, I would have
to stop and I'd have to turn into a video,
that I could share with you,
so you could follow along
and have that same knowledge.
Now the unfortunate part about that is,
I feel like it's really held me back
in my personal progression,
because, basically, for the last six years,
I've had to stop everything that I've been interested in
to produce the videos for YouTube.
- Mmm-hm.
- So it's really limited my creativity,
it's, it's limited my free time,
I don't have much time to tinker,
because... 8 to 12 hours a day making
videos doesn't leave time for anything else,
especially when you're
balancing a family.
So that's when I hit my crisis
on YouTube.
- Mm-hmm.
That's when I decided to stop making YouTube videos,
it was about a year and a half ago.
Mm-hmm. And he took the day off
and we were spending the day...
learning and reading together as a family and...
Grant got an idea...
And he thought, "Well, if I'm going to do this
idea I might as well take my video camera,"
so he... what was that project again?
It was just filling up a balloon with liquid nitrogen.
Yeah and seeing what
would happen.
And so he took his camera,
filled up the balloon with liquid nitrogen
it was pretty awesome, the kids kind of watched and...
You know, it was a little family activity, made a little video of it, put it up on YouTube and it went...
- went crazy.
- Yeah, it did like 5 million views
- in the first couple weeks.
- Yeah,
by the way, that was his first day off
- and he made a video.
- [laughs]
And the funny thing is at the time
my videos that I was pouring my soul into...
putting a 120 hours of production into,
we're getting about 400,000 views.
- So this video that I filmed in 7
minutes and edited in 45 minutes,
- Mmm-hm.
made 5 million views, it just made me stop
and think like rethink my priorities
and rethink my direction.
Because the...
schedule before was now
unsustainable with our family life,
to put that much time and
energy into each project video.
- Yeah
- Which is why we
decided... you know, it's time to
maybe slow down or quit.
Yeah.
There's also a lot of other things
that were happening during making these
is that I never told you about like,
- a real battle I had with an issue called sciatica?
- Mm-hmm
That basically came from sitting,
for five years.
- Yeah. Maybe even more.
- 18...
- 12 to 18 hours a day.
- And you think I'm sitting
- I'm sitting in the cockpit of an airplane,
you know, eight,eight hours a day.
- Yeah, that's true.
And then, I'm sitting in the chair on the computer
and since it's just me doing everything I'm literally...
sitting, sitting, sitting all
day every single day
Not really any time to exercise I'm
just doing all I can to keep up with...
putting out these videos as fast as I can.
I developed sciatica that was
so bad, I couldn't even walk.
- For about 3-4 months.
- Yeah it was so bad,
I couldn't walk, you know, I would
have to stop and bend over
and it looked, it looks so funny if I was ever outside.
You didn't even know that though
- I kept putting out videos every single
week and I was in excruciating pain.
- Mmm-hm.
Um, and I just kind of, there's a lot of
things that I've never told you,
because I don't want to focus on anything negative,
- I just want to stay
positive and to show you the good.
- Mmm-hm.
There's been a lot of battles in the
background to keep things going at the pace...
that we were doing it.
There was a period of about a year-and-a-half,
where I was working so hard on making videos
and there was like a crushing weight
on my chest so heavy,
not, not physical, but
metaphorical,
you know I felt this pressure, I couldn't even breathe,
- like I had trouble breathing.
- Mmm-hm.
Because I was trying to keep up with
the algorithm and keep up with posting,
keep up with the comments,
trying to make you guys happy,
that it was like, affecting my health
and it was pretty serious.
A few other frustrations,
do you know how much time it takes to come up with
an original idea or a modified idea or
something that nobody's ever done before?
And... get this thing all packaged, shiny, presented
and then the next day, have
somebody to come by and take that idea
and put it on their channel and claim it
like they did it themselves.
Like, you know how frustrating it is,
to work so hard to develop something, I mean,
sacrificing time, family, sleep,
to develop something beautiful
and then have somebody else just come and take it and
copy it.
And if those channels are big enough
or if it's put on network television,
all the sudden becomes ambiguous
as to what that source was
and so there's not really any credit so...
I can't tell you how many times ideas
that I've worked on for years.
Were very, very quickly taken
and made ambiguous.
Very, very frustrating, I mean, I'm satisfied,
in the fact that I'm learning these things,
but it would be nice to give credit where credit's due
and one thing I've always tried to do my channel,
is always credit back to my source of inspiration.
If somebody's inspired me, I always
credit back to them in the description
or wherever I can.
And even now, if I get ideas from somebody,
I'll try and bring them on the video, if I can,
or shout them out, or give you a
chance to go check them out.
Because I feel like giving back
is a really great way to go.
So looking at everything in perspective,
you know, having to make some super hard decisions, I mean,
some of my favorite projects:
were taking the microwave
and turning it into an arc welder.
You know, some of those in-depth
technical projects I really enjoyed,
the problem was...
nobody else really wanted to watch them.
So I'd spent six months,
prototyping this microwave welder
and then I put it out there and nobody would watch it.
And yet I'd put out another video that
took me, one or two days to make
- and it would get a million views.
- Or less. Mmm-hm.
So that, I had to make some decisions, I mean,
I know some of you guys in the comments are like,
"Why don't you go back to your old projects?"
and honestly, the answer is: "That's why."
I mean, the people are speaking:
"What are you
gonna watch?"
If I worked really hard on some of these old
uh, type king of random
projects that you claim to love
and it got ten million views,
I would make only
those kinds of projects.
I mean, that's what I love,
that's what I'm passionate about.
But when... when nobody's watching,
that I can't pay the bills, it's not sustainable.
I-I've gotta do something else, that's a, a nice balance,
create content that I'm still proud of,
uh, do experiments I'm proud of,
but it can't be the workload...
of something that's not going appreciated.
Now, I love creators like,
The Hacksmith and Colin Furze,
I think they're amazing, they're great channels,
- they're they're blowing up
their contents doing great.
- Mmm-hm.
But if you also dig back into the numbers,
they're not being appreciated for the
kind of content they're doing either.
I mean, they're working really hard,
they're coming up with ingenious ideas.
They're putting it out there and every now
and then, they get some nice big spikes,
but on average, like people just
don't resonate to that content
or the content is so hard to make,
you can only put it out every two
or three weeks or every month.
And when you're doing that on the YouTube algorithm,
there's just not enough sustainability
to really make it worth it.
I mean, unless you're bringing
in, uh, brand sponsorships but...
it takes a long time to get on the radar
for those kind of sponsorships.
And they're not easy to do, especially when you're doing,
you know, mad science experiments,
it's hard to get through the legal department.
A lot of that stuff's
difficult to get approved.
I tried setting up a Patreon account once,
to try and get funding for the
kind of thing that we are doing
and got very little support, it's very discouraging.
I think, because people were
looking at the numbers of the...
on the side of the channel,
the numbers of subscribers
and basically kicking back saying,
"You're too big for that."
So I had to shut down the Patreon
account, because it just wasn't worth it.
So the only other options, really
are just to make more content,
get more sponsorships or
try and sell some kind of merchandise.
So, the good news is, we found a
new way to make videos,
I could do my daily experiments,
um, I started bringing on a guy to help film and help edit
and because we were doing frequent posting,
you know, there luckily there was, uh, enough revenue,
that we could support another
family on that income.
- It was really nice to have the help...
- Mmm-hm.
to do that.
Now what got really interesting, is in December,
- we tried this experiment where
we tried posting daily videos...
- Right.
and that pushed us to the max, because
we were literally all, all day and all night
- and up till 4:00 in the morning working
on videos to post every day.
- Yeah.
But that made such a huge difference with our channel,
we gained 800,000 subscribers in a month,
the revenues shot through the roof and
it seemed like everything was life changing.
- And this was just Grant and one
other guy doing that.
- Right.
which was an incredible workload for both of them.
So this is when I realized, if we could
keep this up, if this was sustainable,
you know, you guys are asking,
"What's the creative process?"
"How to get from point A to point B?"
"Do you ever make mistakes?"
Um, and also giving requests like, "Can you
do this project for that project?"
This format met that need
and we were able
to do it on a daily basis.
So once I saw that it was sustainable,
that the money could come in,
I decided to systematize what we were doing,
- hire a team and go to work.
- Mmm-hm.
So I took basically, three weeks off in January,
to figure out what I was doing
put it into a system,
I hired two more editors,
I taught them the system and we developed
this, uh, machine that we can now film,
put videos into the machine and
produce on a daily basis.
Now the problem with doing that is...
there's still no time for research,
development, and prototyping,
because all of our work is into production.
And if I stop,
work on production, to do research and
development,
there aren't videos and if there aren't videos,
there's no income to pay for all
those editors and the people helping.
So there's this really weird balance here,
that I want you guys to understand,
some of the comments say, "We liked your videos better
when you post once a week or even once a month."
But if I post once a month,
there's not even gonna be enough
money for me to make videos,
so "The King of Random" is dead.
Okay? If I posted once a week, I can support myself,
but now I'm trapped back in that position,
where I have no time for anything else.
If I post daily, then now I'm in a
position where I can have a team
helping me to produce high-quality daily content
and the only thing that we need now,
is the re-infusion of the DIY,
and we're almost to that point. I'll tell
you about that in a second.
But think about this we have to
film videos,
that are a little bit easier to film,
because... I don't have projects lined up it
takes time to develop ideas, new ideas,
especially ideas you know are
just going to be stolen
- and re-purposed anyway.
- [laughs]
So right now, we're in this transition period,
where a lot of the projects that
I'm doing, are a little bit easier,
because they're just experiments.
I know some of the people are kicking
back about experiments right now,
because we want to see the old DIY
projects, we want to see old projects.
Um, well I hope I've given some
context into how much work it has taken,
to make those DIY projects.
Only to find out that they
don't get really watched as much
and then people take the ideas
and claim the credit for them anyway.
So I don't really have a lot of motivation,
to do those types of project, I'm not rewarded for that.
However, I think there's a way we
can still make it work,
now that we've built this production machine,
we've got people on board,
you're helping support multiple families now.
A lot of different people are depending on this,
so we need to post daily videos
If we don't post daily videos,
- people are going to lose their jobs, okay?
- Mmm-hm.
And "The King of Random" is going to shut down.
But now that we've got this thing built, instead
of being the one tinkering, prototyping,
and working on things every day,
my next step now I'm on a hunt,
- for the next "King of Random"
or "The King of Random" sidekick.
- Mmm-hm
Basically, somebody that I can bring
on board, I can give them instructions.
And every day is going to be
plasma cutting, working with, uh, wood,
and you know, welding, and building desktop
weapons, and trying experiments and...
creative prototyping all these things
and getting to the point where...
we can bring those to the table film them
andput out high quality content on a very regular basis.
With that DIY aspect
It's just taking time to get there, because,
you got to remember, I've only started these
systems in February we're only a couple months
down the road and I think we've
made some extreme progress.
- Mmm-hm.
- You know?
- Yeah, and this is kind of a combination
of what it all comes back to from where it started.
Is just time in the shop for Grant to tinker
and this is where...
we're kind of looking for somebody
that has a mind that wants to push...
science, and projects...
and prototyping to the boundaries.
So where we're kind of at is an all-or-nothing situation,
because I can tinker in the shop
and I can come up with new...
"King of Random" ideas all day long,
I love doing that, that's my element.
Grant will never run out of ideas,
because he's always spinning with ideas,
the problem is the time commitment
to make the videos.
And that's, that's the real problem,
because to actually make the videos,
take so much time, there's no time left to tinker.
I mean when's the last time I actually
sat down my shop and just tinkered...
- for days on end.
- Yeah,
it's been a while and, and Grant could
spend days on end, just tinkering and tinkering,
- Yeah.
- but he's also got this...
incredible work ethic.
You know, as you've seen in the story,
he had sleep in his car, just to save money,
- to get to the purpose
of what he was aiming towards...
- Mmm-hm.
at any time in his life, that's always what he does.
As he... uses his resources to create...
the very best and most purposeful way
to get to the end result.
So, you know, when we were living in a...
small basement apartment and
you know, saving lots of money.
He had lots of free time to tinker and play,
and prototype with all these things that he loved.
And then started making videos
and then that became kind of the...
the project is making the videos
out of all these things.
And now we're going back, to how do
we get more of that time to tinker.
That's right, and this is the frustration I've
had with making videos from the beginning,
I feel held back...
- by making videos. I feel like the last year...
- Mmm-hm.
I've done nothing, but make videos I spent every day...
working on systems and ways
to bring you content on a daily basis.
Because, I know there are
people out there that really need that.
- Mmm-hm.
- You know, this is bigger than just me,
so I, I'm with this dilemma, now where I could
shut down "The King of Random" we could...
we could be fine, I could be happy,
I could be a great dad for my kids,
I could play with everything I want, but
none of you are ever going to know about it
- Right.
- On the other hand,
I can try and find some way, where I can
get that freedom back to tinker and play,
and have a system in place,
to develop that content,
to where you can have it
on a consistent basis as well.
- Mmm-hm.
And I'm always up for a challenge,
so I'm looking for a way,
to make the best of both worlds work.
So please, bear with me, this is a transition
process, it's never really been done before,
there's nobody out there doing it because it's extremely,
- extremely difficult.
- And very time-intensive,
and a lot of focus,
and really purposeful energy
- goes into creating something like
this and it does take time.
- Yeah.
And there's no other platform in the world right now,
that has the resources that we have,
the subscriber base that you are,
the ideas that surround us,
and you know, the the funding from sponsorships and...
Google Adsense to make all this happen.
So we are literally blazing new trails, we're
pushing new boundaries and sometimes...
when we push new boundaries,
they're going to break, we make mistakes.
I'm an experimenter, I experiment
with you guys to see how you react.
Some of these recent collaborations...
- It's an experiment.
- It's an experiment, yeah, so...
don't judge the whole channel by a couple of videos,
- where you see somebody that
you may or may not like.
- Mmm-hm.
Um, it's all part of an experiment,
it's all growing to a greater good,
and if you're worried about the kind of
content on the channel, just know that...
I'm trying to live out my passions, in a way,
that you can experience them with me.
And remember, that this whole process is evolutionary.
You know for Grant but also for the
way that YouTube has progressed,
the way that life has progressed and
the way we can share that with you.
- That's right.
- So...
- I mean...
here are really the options:
you want to leave so many negative
comments and thumbs down my video,
I lose motivation, I stop making videos.
If I take a week or two off to prototype
tinker, and bring back those old projects,
my revenues drop, to the point,
where it's not sustainable for me,
I stopped making videos.
It's a really delicate balance to be able to...
make a living off of doing something
that you love,
but also be able to employ other
people produce on a regular schedule,
it would be extremely easy
for me, just to quit, to give up, to stop
and to... relieve the burden.
I mean, I've been carrying this burden
for seven years making videos
for YouTube and not really knowing why.
I'm just doing it, because I know there are
people out there benefiting and sharing
and I want to share
the joy of what we're doing.
But if people are taking the joy out of it,
it really affects my motivation to continue.
So you just have to trust me. We are...
putting systems into place we've
got a machine working now
and we're jump-starting that machine,
we're getting it working, we're working on the bugs,
we're moving it, to becoming a well-oiled machine
and we're almost at the point now where
we can start bringing back the DIY
and those projects that are time consuming.
Because that is where the passion comes from
and that is where Grant's heart is
and always has been.
- Yeah.
- It's just that, he's very, you know,
he takes to heart what you guys say
and what you guys think,
and what you guys want, because...
from his passion that he shared with you
he loves the feedback that he gets from you.
You know, good and bad he takes it to
heart and he kind of adjusts...
based on what you guys want,
because part of his passion,
is sharing it and sharing the joy that he
finds in the projects that he's doing.
If you keep watching the videos,
you enable me to build a team of
people who can get you that content,
that I'm passionate about.
Because it's never going to stop,
I mean, we've got content every time.
You know, we have our weekly
date night and we talk about things,
you know, for hours on our date night and
every night we talk about things...
and Grant's use off, you know 5, 10, 20 ideas,
- [baby noise]
- just about every day,
every night, every week.
and I'm, I'm blown away at the
amount of ideas
that he could produce, that he wants
to produce, that he wants to play with
and tinker with in his shop and develop into videos.
But again it
goes back to the issue
of how much time do we have to do that when
we're producing on a certain schedule.
And I'm a dad, guys, I'm a dad and
a husband, first and foremost,
and I don't want my family to grow up
and leave home and never have
known their dad,
- who was sitting right there at home the whole time.
- On the computer.
Yeah, you just have to understand how many sacrifices
are being made to produce these videos.
So much is going into it
and it might be easy to say, "Well, don't
spend as much time making the videos."
But if you don't do that,
you don't get surfaced on YouTube, you
don't get the Adsense revenues that you need,
- [baby noise]
- which means the whole thing falls apart
and you don't make any videos.
So we are trying to do the best of everything,
we're trying to produce the
content that you love, that we love,
that the internet loves, that YouTube supports,
and that can... employ a number of different families.
And it is happening, it is happening,
my mind is always spinning and the more
that I can get away from the video production,
the more creative that I can be,
in bringing more ideas to you. So,
the hunt for "The King of Random" sidekick is on,
because I need, I need a protege, I need a prototype.
Somebody whose mind works,
the way Grant does in a lot of
ways, that can tinker, that has a really good...
understanding of the laws of science and
somebody that likes to push the boundaries.
Yep, I need a full-time me,
that can just spend all day, every day
on the shop working on things.
And then develop the ideas
and get them more film ready,
I need a team
that can produce that,
and then I need free time to spend with my family,
and make sure that my kids develop properly as well,
and don't grow up without a dad.
[clap] Happy Father's Day!
Here's where we'd like to go, guys I...
am bringing on a sidekick I'm going to
bring on a full-time carbon copy of myself,
who can spend all day prototyping, tinkering,
and getting those awesome "King of Random"
projects back in the pipeline.
I've got a production team who can
take the content that we film
and put out daily videos.
That's the goal:
daily videos and experiments.
And... I want to get to a point, where I can
be removed from the system enough,
to where I can have more creativity,
more vision, more time to
tinker, and really feel fulfilled...
in following my passions
and my desires
and spending time with my family as well.
And like I said before,
Grant is full of ideas
and they just seem to come in a
never-ending stream
and that's part of the passion that
we want to share with you is...
the exploration of these ideas.
And I especially get my ideas,
when I'm removed from the system,
because when I'm
tied to producing
or daily schedule and you got to realize
putting out a video takes the entire day, because...
we're following up on comments and we're
watching the reactions,
we're seeing as the thumbnails are
working well, do we need to change the titles?
and my mind is tied to that I'm not thinking of new ideas.
So the best thing for all of us really is...
please keep supporting us, by
watching every video we put out,
- maybe watch it twice.
- [laughs]
- And...
- If you love it.
- [chuckle]
- And by doing that,
you'll be enabling this system
that will support the content
creation of new projects, new DIY's,
there's nobody positioned as effectively as we are,
to give you what you're asking for.
So just work with me, work with us, and allow me...
to get to a place where I can have
the freedom, the vision, the ability...
to bring on more people and
infuse more content back to you.
Yeah and this is a
very artistic process too and...
we need that time for creativity,
because we've got the content, we just
need to be able to have the time space,
- to give it to you
in a way that you love.
-  That's it
And we do love you guys,
we love meeting you in person and
one thing that I've done this
year that I've never done before,
was come out on camera.
That's why, I'm in all my videos now,
that's why I'm going to live events,
- [baby noise]
- that's why I'm hanging out with creators
and spending time with people,
this is all very new for me. Because...
as Janae said, I'm very private person,
I'm very introverted.
So for me, to come out this is a new
pushing the boundaries, pushing the bubble.
- It's a new experiment.
- It's a new experiment, for me.
Really, it is a new experiment!
And part of the evolution of Grant and "The King of
Random" in our life process together.
That's it. So we appreciate you guys, if
you want "The King of Random" to continue,
it really is up to you. I'm going to do my best...
to stick to my standards, to be true to myself,
to be true to you,
and I really want to give you the
experiences that you're asking for. So...
if you want to see certain projects
done on my channel, then upvote
those project ideas in the comments,
so that I see them, because the ones that I see,
are the ones that I'm doing.
And so I don't really want to get kickback...
from people saying, "All you do is these."
Because that's what you're asking for you guys,
if you want something different,
ask for something different,
I'm doing the best I can to meet those needs,
we're all here on a dream together,
we're going to the same
place, it's all good, it's all positive,
and it's really all up to you. Keep
supporting us, we'll keep supporting you.
- Thanks for watching!
- Thanks for watching.
[laughs]
We call good?
[baby noise]